Here on Journey to the Microcosmos, we have
a complicated relationship with worms.
On the one hand, they are gross.
They wiggle around.
They end up in body parts.
They cause disease.
All those things aren't great.
On the other hand, they’re everywhere.
You cannot escape worms, especially in the
microcosmos.
And given everything we have said about how
gross worms are, that doesn’t sound like
good news.
But there’s something to be said for ubiquity.
Absence may make the heart grow fonder, but
constant worm encounters can go a long way too.
We might even have a little affection for
them at this point.
So today, we’re going to look back on some of those
many encounters and see what it is that makes
worms so hard to ignore.
Let’s start out though by talking
about what a worm actually even is.
There are no ghosts in the microcosmos.
There is no Halloween in the microcosmos.
But if there were, this flatworm would fit
in quite nicely with its spectral appearance.
It might be navigating its way through a field
of other organisms, but it looks like it had
three minutes to prepare for a costume party
and decided to go with the classic “old
bedsheet with eyeholes” ghost costume.
And maybe comparing this flatworm (or even
worms in general) to a ghost is kind of apt.
Ghosts straddle two worlds, and so do worms,
though in their case, instead of bridging
the realm of the living and dead, worms manage
to stretch between the micro and the macro.
And akin to ghosts, worms might seem like
a sort of reduced form of life.
After all, for a lot of us, worms are the
wiggly tubes that we dug up from playgrounds.
And of all of the worms, flatworms are perhaps
the most simple of all.
But even digging into what it means to be
the simplest worm makes the whole notion of
simplicity seem ludicrous.
So let’s start with the broader question:
what are worms, other than wiggly, self-mating
tubes?
While we generally use the word “worm”
to describe many different, unrelated, invertebrate,
tubular animals that belong to a number of
different phyla, there are three main phyla
that people focus on.
The first are our flatworm buddies here, who
are known more formally as Platyhelminthes.
Then there is the phylum Nematoda, known less
formally as roundworms.
We’ve come across nematodes many times in
our journey through the microcosmos, which
makes sense given that they are one of the
most abundant animals on this planet.
And last are the Annelida, phylum of our playground
friend, the earthworm.
While earthworms are a bit beyond the scope
of the micro, if you will, we’ve also got
this little Stylaria lacustris.
At the tip of its head is the proboscis, an
antenna-like structure that the worm uses
for feeding.
And as we scan past the head, you can see
that the length of the Stylaria’s body is
segmented.
Of the three phyla we’ve mentioned, annelids
are the most complex.
They have a closed circulatory system with
tubes that transport nutrients and oxygen
throughout their body, as well as a complete
digestive system that has both a mouth to
take in food and an anus to get rid of waste.
If we think of worms in general as a gut enclosed
within a body wall, then that gut is a tube
and the body is a tube, and you can imagine
that worms are a tube inside a tube.
Now what separates these different groups
is the space that separates one of those tubes
from the other.
Complex systems inside annelids are due to
what’s called a coelom, a tissue-lined cavity
that sits between the tube of the digestive
tract and the tube of the body wall.
Importantly, this cavity is filled with fluid,
which facilitates the development of organs
along with the transport of nutrients around
the body.
The development of the first coelom was a
very big deal because coeloms don’t just
allow annelids to have complex systems.
They connect the seemingly simple organisms
we’re talking about here to more complex
animals—like us!
Because annelids and humans are both what
is known as coelomates, or eucoelomates.
We are animals that have coeloms.
So, thank you to the ancestor that we share
with earthworms who developed the first coelom,
who allowed more complex organisms like you
to exist.
Nematodes, on the other hand, are what are
called pseudocoelomates.
They still have a coelom-like fluid-filled
cavity, but the cavity isn’t lined with
tissue like you find in true coeloms.
Other microscopic pseudocoelomates include
gastrotrichs and rotifers.
This pseudocoelom is a slight but significant
difference in nematodes when compared to annelids,
corresponding to a slightly less complex body
plan, though nematodes
still do have a complete digestive system.
The flatworms are the simplest of all.
Starting with the coelom: flatworms don’t
actually have one.
They’re considered acoelomates.
That area between the gut and body wall where
annelids and nematodes have a cavity full
of fluid is instead full of tissue.
This has a few consequences for the flatworm,
but one of the biggest ones is that this area
can’t support the development of specialized
systems that you see in other animals.
The lack of coelom imposes limits on the flatworm’s
body and lifestyle, reducing both its complexity
and size.
But that does not mean the flatworm lives
a simple life.
Of the three worm groups, flatworms are the
most like a tube within another tube, except
that their outer tube is much less cylindrical.
The “flat” in “flatworm” is actually
an adaptation: without a circulatory system
or respiratory system, the worm relies on
diffusion across its outer membrane to supply
cells with oxygen.
Being flatter gets the cells closer to the
outside and better positioned for diffusion.
And without the ability to build a complete
digestive system like those found in nematodes
and annelids, flatworms have to adjust to
life without that most under-appreciated body
part of all: the anus.
They take in food through one opening, digest
it in their gut, and then spew the waste back
out from that same opening.
So unlike other organisms who have separate
entrances and exits for their food, the flatworm
must wait to finish digesting before it can
eat again.
But this is not the only way flatworms can
get rid of waste.
Their body is lined with a special type of
cell called a flame cell that also gets waste
out of the worm.
While it may not have the elegance of an interconnected
set of organs, this system is its own form
of complexity.
Basically, every flame cell is one single-celled
kidney, allowing the worm to just...ooze waste
from its skin.
And this is just scratching the surface of
the biological intricacy flatworms are capable
of.
Like many of their more involved worm counterparts,
flatworms can reproduce both asexually and
sexually.
And when reproducing sexually, they can mate
with another flatworm, or even with themselves--both
making and fertilizing their own eggs.
There’s also those flatworm species that
can regenerate, a trick that our more developed
bodies are, alas, not capable of.
Even the many weird ways they move make the
word “wiggle” feel reductive.
Our perception of simplicity across nature
is built on comparisons.
Compared to us, an earthworm may seem simple.
Put that earthworm next to a flatworm, and
suddenly the earthworm represents a gigantic
biological advancement.
But then put that flatworm next to a bacteria,
and suddenly it contains multitudes, it is a universe.
That flatworm is a marvel, an almost unbelievable
testament to the power of evolution.
So we started with the simplest worm of all.
And if you’re someone who is skeptical that
worms can be interesting, then maybe watching
a simple, jiggly tube was not enough to sway
you.
But nature has a way of building on simplicity,
creating fascinating creatures out of even
the most basic of blueprints.
And that brings us to the next worm we’re
going to focus on…
the ones we affectionately call “polka-dotted
vacuum worms.”
We recently did an episode
about nematodes,
the phylum of worm that outnumbers
just about every animal on this planet.
Now, it's not the most striking of animals,
but the nematode has had a few
distinguished scientific decades,
thanks to its many uses in laboratories.
So as far as worms go,
the nematode seems to dominate
much of our scientific understanding.
But worms, despite their seemingly simple
bodies, are a diverse bunch.
Which is why we thought for today it might
be fun to visit with a less famous worm
and like one of those relatives
that you don't really know very much about
But every time you see them,
there's a new strange story to unpack
They are the Aeolosomatids,
a family of freshwater worms.
The ones that you see here are invaders.
They showed up uninvited
in a blepharisma culture that
James, our master of microscopes,
has been taken care of for a long time.
And while Aeolosoma worms are
you know, worms,
they are in a different class of worm
because as we have seen before,
there are, in fact, many ways to be a tube.
Where nematodes are roundworms,
Aeolosoma are segmented,
placing them in the Annelid phylum,
along with earthworms and leeches,
Aeolosoma are usually several millimeters
in length,
their bodies divided into more
than ten segments that you can see
scrunching up and expanding as the worm
wiggles its way through the microcosmos.
The Aeolosoma are striking to look at.
You can see their organs
through their transparent bodies,
and as it moves, bundles of long bristly
hairs wave along the side of its body.
Those hairs mark the Aeolosoma
as a specific type of an annelid
called a polychaete, or bristle worm.
Some bristle worms are found
in unusual places like hydrothermal vents,
but our Aeolosoma come
from a much more mundane home.
They're usually found in bodies
of fresh water where they'd like to crawl
among the leaves and algae
that settle at the bottom of the water.
And inside their bodies
are colorful gland cells,
though no one is really sure
what those cells exist for
or why they have their particular colors.
And some species, the cells are green
and others they're yellow.
And sometimes,
as with our worms, they're red.
The final result is a worm
that looks a little like it
ran into a porcupine
while also having caught chicken pox.
While there are some Aeolosoma
species that reproduce sexually,
most reproduce asexually dividing
to form a copy of itself.
The Aeolosoma creates its clone at its end,
linking the old and new versions of itself
like a chain.
You can see the new Aeolosoma here,
looking like it's attached to the other’s
butt because,
it's attached to the other’s butt.
And this chain can keep going
as the Aeolosoma
keeps dividing, adding more worms
that are connected together
so that the final length
of their combined bodies sometimes
reaches around ten millimeters total.
That's ten millimeters of clones
combined to create one giant mega worm
until eventually the chain breaks
and they all go their separate ways.
So when James found these worms
invading his samples, you'd think
maybe this would be an exciting find.
Here is a culture full of bristled,
polka-dotted, chain-forming clones.
What could be more exciting!
Well, as wonderful as they are to
look at these invasions are not ideal
because they are also essentially vacuum cleaners.
Their mouths are lined with cilia
that wave around and help the worms
suction up bits of plant and animal debris.
When they're in a pond,
They like to crawl across leaves
and algae for their meals.
But when you find them
in bottles of ciliate cultures,
you've been lovingly maintaining,
that's when things get a bit dicier.
Because Aeolosoma will eat
just about anything, including each other.
Indeed.
in one very dramatic scene
documented in 1901 scientists
observing the species Aeolosoma tenebrarum
described the way
these chains of worms
would twist up in each other,
creating a writhing, tangled ball of worms
that would stay stuck together
for long periods of time.
And when the scientists pulled
these balls apart, they usually found
at least one worm
that had been partially eaten.
I'm sure the etiquette around
cannibalistic frenzies varies,
but for most animals, getting eaten
by another member of your species
would seem, at the very least,
a little rude.
But when you're Aeolosoma,
it's not that big of a deal.
Honestly, it's not much
more than an inconvenience,
because if a part of it gets eaten,
it can always regenerate.
In one case, the scientists watching these
balls of worms found that one worm had its
head eaten.
But in about three days
it was able to make a new one.
It would probably have taken less time
to regenerate other parts of their body-
heads seemed to take the Aeolosoma a bit longer,
perhaps because of all the complex parts
that need to be rebuilt.
And the Aeolosoma can regenerate even
when it is cut into multiple segments.
This superpower has made one species
called Aeolosoma viride
particularly interesting to scientists.
And it's not just
that they can regenerate.
After all, as incredible as this ability
is, there are plenty of other animals
that can regenerate as well.
But scientists aren't just interested
in how animals regenerate.
They also want to know how
those regenerative abilities
change as the animal gets older.
That's a difficult question to study
because as you might expect,
self-healing animals have often, pretty long
lifespans.
So it's a challenge to wait years
or even decades to study how their ability
to regenerate changes
with the wear and tear of aging.
Aeolosoma viride
however, has a lifespan
of only about two months,
which means it goes from young to old
on a manageable timescale for scientists
cycling through experiments.
And that makes it a useful organism
to observe how that capacity
to rebuild itself changes
as the worm ages.
But as useful as regeneration
is for survival,
it is not the only tool
the worm relies on.
After all, not all dangers can easily
be patched up by rebuilding body parts.
Sometimes the worm has to preempt
dangerous conditions, and for that
it turns to the cyst.
In nature, the worms will likely begin
forming these cysts in autumn,
when the water gets cold and begins to fill
with the remains of decomposing life.
And as the temperatures continue
to fall, the worms begin to slow down,
crawling to areas full of delicious debris
for them to stock up on, and eventually,
the worms begin to secrete a mucus,
creating a gooey
shell that then hardens into a cyst.
You can see the granules of red pigment
swirling around as the worm moves inside.
Some of that activity
might be the peristaltic movement
of its intestines, but it's also possible
that the warmth of the microscope lamp
is causing the worms to stir as well.
And in their ponds,
when warm weather comes, the worm
will get ready to emerge from its encased
hibernation, using its head
to push at the hardened case of its cyst
until it manages to poke a hole through
from which it can escape.
It can take a worm anywhere
from 30 minutes
to several hours to make its exit.
And if there's a thick
coating of bacteria on the cyst,
it may even take the worms several days.
And from there well,
it is a life of suction,
feeding and chain
link clones and regenerating.
Perhaps not normal to us,
but what's normal anyway?
Especially when you're a worm.
Now that we’ve seen a few worms, have you
ever wondered what it would be like
to live inside of one?
Because I certainly haven’t.
But there is a ciliate that does like to live
in the guts of worms, so in our next video,
we’re going to learn more about why they
do that.
You’ve heard some worm horror stories, right?
We were looking some up just for this episode
and came across a recent headline
from ArsTechnicathat read,
“Army of worm larvae hatch from man’s
bum, visibly slither under his skin,”.
And if that’s not enough to terrify you,
and make you feel very uncomfortable
there’s always the stories of painful stomach
cramps or diarrhea or nausea that eventually
turns out to be caused by some worms that
have taken up residence in someone’s intestines.
It is terrifying and wild to think of something
so much smaller than us causing so much havoc.
So, as we watch the cilia lining a worm’s
gut beat its own soothing pattern, wouldn’t
it feellike,
almost like, a little bit of justice if this
sight wasn’t so peaceful? If worms had to
worry about their own guts being taken over
by a parasite?
If you’ve found yourself in this position,
seeking schadenfreude over a worm, well we
have some good news for you. The worm you
see in the middle of this tank is currently
hosting this strange fellow, called a Radiophyra.
James, our master of microscopes, had been
on the hunt for the Radiophyra after seeing
this: two radiophyras linked together in a
chain as one divided to make more copies of
itself. It had come from the inside of one
of the worms he’d been watching, when he’d
accidentally squeezed a worm a bit too hard
under the coverslip and caused the ciliate
to pop out.
Radiophyra belong to a general group of ciliates
called Astomes, or astomatid ciliates. We’ve
talked about ciliates a lot on our channel,
which means that if you’ve been watching
us for a while, you may have picked up on
the fact that from time to time, we have said
that most ciliates have an oral groove, that
opening lined with cilia that sweep bacteria
and algae and other tiny bits of food into
the organism. We’ve seen that oral groove
at work in ciliates like stentors and paramecium,
functioning as the ciliate equivalent of a
mouth.
But as we have always said most ciliates,
you
will have inferred, that this does not mean
all ciliates.
And if you are looking for an exception
to the rule,
astomes are that exception. Astomatid ciliates
are diverse, but they are unified by one shared
feature, or rather, they are unified by their
lack of one shared feature, a mouth.
And they don’t need a mouth because they
have something even better. They have worms.
Astomatid ciliates do parasitize animals other
than worms. Some live inside mollusks, others
inside leeches or even in amphibians. But
they are most commonly associated with the
guts of annelid worms. So when James found
his Radiophyra, he decided to see if he could
find more of them in the other worms that
were in his samples. And that meant that our
master of microscopes had to become a master
of worm surgery, dissecting them so he could
draw out the ciliates living within.
In–side this particular aquatic worm were
these astomatid ciliates. From a distance,
they also look like worms.
But as you get closer…
And closer, their shape becomes more definite
except for the massive amounts of fluff around
them, a dense cloud of cilia beating away.
Unfortunately, there isn’t a lot of research
on this ciliate. In fact, there isn’t a
lot of research on astomatid ciliates in general.
They just aren’t destructive enough or common
enough to have become either a necessary or
convenient research subject. In fact, it’s
not even clear whether or not we should call
them parasites. Modern day papers will sometimes
refer to them endosymbionts instead, because
we don't know a lot about whether astomatid
ciliates are doing much to their worm hosts,
bad or good.
But the worm gut does plenty for the astomatid
ciliates. At one point in time, the ancestors
of these ciliates did have mouths. But as
they found their way into worms, and specifically
their guts, those oral grooves became less
and less necessary.
Instead, the ciliates could rely on a form
of feeding called osmotrophy, where they simply
absorb nutrients from their surroundings through
osmosis. Instead of taking in larger bits
of food through their mouths and breaking
it down themselves, astomatid ciliates could
just take advantage of the worm’s digestive
system to do all that breaking down for them.
As the worm’s
digestive enzymesbreak down complex molecules
into
simpler forms that can travel through their
own intestinal walls,
some of those nutrients would just go feed
the astomatid ciliate instead.
These ciliates will actually sometimes be
picky about making sure they’re in a particular
spot within their host’s intestinal tract.
And once they’ve found the right spot, the
ciliates hold themselves in place with organelles
that range in shape, some use hooks, other
spines, or maybe even suckers. The flat shape
of the ciliates helps them stay pressed to
the epithelium of the intestines. So while
these ciliates may not need a mouth anymore,
they have found other traits necessary to
their survival.
Astomatid ciliates are found in hosts from
all sorts of environments. Some live in soil.
Some live in ponds. Some even live in ocean
waters. And scientists are using the general
tools available now to try and piece together
how host and endosymbiont have shaped each
other. We can see some of that intertwined
story in the ciliate’s mouthless-ness, but
the specifics of that evolutionary change
are laid out in their DNA, as are the other
more hidden parts of that shared history.
Now we cannot know whether worms have any
feelings about their guts being home to another
organism. They likely don’t have much choice
in the matter, and they also likely aren’t
prone to emotions like resentment the way
we might resent a worm parasitizing our bodies.
But if they were to have any feelings on the
matter, we want to offer this one last detail
about astomatid ciliates: many of them have
their own endosymbionts as well, bacteria
that live inside them with perhaps their own
history tangled up with their ciliate host’s
story as well. Now we couldn’t find those
bacteria in our parasitic friends, but we
like the idea that somewhere out there are
these nesting dolls of endosymbiosis: an organism
that is an organism but an organism that is
also a home buried within other homes.
When we say that worms are everywhere, we
mean it.
Even in the world of science, worms are widespread
with researchers turning to the nematode Caenorhabditis
elegans as a model to study all sorts of questions.
And in the process, scientists have written
some lovely things about the nematodes that
make their work possible.
So in our next video, we’ll pay tribute
to a worm that has shaped our world in so
many ways.
When it comes to the muses of the animal kingdom,
the nematode seems like an unlikely well of
inspiration.
There may be poems about tigers burning bright,
and epic fantasy tales featuring giant birds.
But nematodes have two obvious factors working
against them achieving that kind of mythical
status.
First: they are worms.
And let's not generalize too broadly, but
their
simple tubular bodies are just not what most
people think of when it comes to the beauty
of the natural world.
Second: most of them are really tiny, their
length measured in millimeters.
It’s hard to be inspired by an animal that
is likely to escape one’s notice entirely.
Though we should note that there are nematodes
that can grow quite long—the largest discovered
was found in the placenta of a sperm whale,
and it measured between 8-9 meters in length.
But even that seems more likely to inspire
more nightmares than art.
In 1914, a scientist named Nathan Cobb wrote
the following about nematodes:
Nematodes do not furnish hides, horns, tallow,
or wool.
They are not fit for food, they do not produce
anything fit to eat;
neither do they sing or amuse us in any way;
nor are they ornamental
—in fact, when they are displayed in museums
the public votes them hideous.
Judging from that quote, Cobb seems to understand
the common consensus on nematodes,
which is that if there is to be a consensus,
it is not a positive one.
But Cobb wrote this as part of a 34 page paper
on nematodes titled “Nematodes and their
Relationships,”
which wonderfully documents
his fascination with the worm and argues for
their importance to our understanding of the
world.
So clearly, he found something inspiring about
the nematode.
But there is another quote from this research
paper that you may have even heard before,
it is pretty famous in nematode circles.
And The quote is as follows:
In short, if all the matter in the universe
except the nematodes were swept away,
our world would still be dimly recognizable,
and if, as disembodied spirits, we could then
investigate it, we should find its mountains,
hills, vales, rivers, lakes, and oceans represented
by a film of nematodes.
Cobb paints a world overrun by nematodes,
an image
created by his own experience with studying
them.
But when he wrote this, he likely didn’t
have the means
to estimate just how many nematodes there
are in the world.
But in 2019, researchers estimated that there
are about 57 billion nematodes in the world
for every human in the world.
In addition, their total biomass is about
300 million tons.
And that’s just for the soil nematodes.
When you take into consideration nematodes
living in freshwater or marine habitats or
inside of other animals, the numbers only
go up from there.
Nematodes are considered to be one of the
most abundant animals on earth.
But the beauty of Cobb’s writing on their
abundance
is that he doesn’t just capture the notion
of the numbers.
The world he describes isn’t just a mass
of worms that we’ve been allowed space inside
of.
The world he describes—the one that we live
in—has its forms and landscapes sculpted
and cultivated by worms, their bodies shaped
around and inside trees and plants and animals.
Of course, not all of those links between
nematodes
and other organisms are always so pleasant.
In “Nematodes and their Relationships,”
Cobb mentions that he once removed over 40,000
nematodes from the stomach of a wallaby.
And if that isn’t daunting enough to imagine,
there are always the ancient texts that date
back thousands of years, documenting intestinal
worms found in people.
There are also the nematode eggs that have
been
found preserved in mummies and in fossilized
poop.
In the 19th century, scientists were able
to show that the parasite Ascaris lumbricoides
which resides in the intestines and produces
eggs
that are passed on through poop
finds its way into people who have ingested
their eggs
on contaminated food.
To prove this, a scientist named Giovanni
Battista Grassi infected himself with their
eggs and then hunted for those eggs in his
feces.
A peculiar aside here this is not the first
time we’ve described a scientist hunting
through his own poop for evidence of the microcosmos
you can watch our Leeuwenhoek episode
for more tales of this type.
Now there are plenty of other
nematode parasites that have
their own unique life cycles and horrifying
effects.
Some worms are transmitted through the soil,
others through insects.
Some inflame the limbs, others trigger massive
blood loss.
Nematodes can also parasitize plants, attacking
the roots or stem or flowers,
sometimes destroying entire crops in the process.
And so with such a destructive path, the nematode
feels like an enemy, something we study only
to understand how we can fight it.
But Cobb asks a simple question in his writing:
What would be our conception of the insect
group as a whole if our knowledge was largely
confined to these simple and
degenerate parasitic forms?
In the case of insects, we have enough experience
with them to know that whatever squeamishness
they inspire, they are also integral parts
of our world.
And likewise most nematodes are actually free-living
species.
It’s just that the parasites have come to
dominate both our imagination and our knowledge
because of their proximity and their consequences
for our health.
But those massively abundant soil nematodes
they are vital to our world,
feeding on bacteria and fungi.
In the process, they release nitrogen back
into the soil, sustaining other organisms
and plants that may use it.
A healthy soil is full of these free-living
nematodes, whose presence reflects the overall
diversity of microbes around them.
The information is all there, it is up to
us to uncover their secrets.
Perhaps this why Cobb ended “Nematodes and
their relationships” with this call to arms
for the field of nematology:
They offer an exceptional field of study;
and probably constitute among the last great
organic group worthy of a separate branch
of biological science comparable with entomology—
nematology.
We can’t speak to any claims that the nematode
is the quote “last great organic group”
worthy of its own branch of study.
But we do feel that he has been vindicated
by the fact that one of the most popular model
organisms used today is a free-living nematode:
Caenorhabditis elegans, better known as C.
elegans.
While the worm is found in soils all over
the world, what it’s perhaps best known
for is the life it lives in labs.
While scientists had described various aspects
of C. elegans life early in the 20th century,
it wasn’t until 1965 that the scientist
Sydney Brenner turned to the worm as a model
organism, relying on its fast life cycle,
small size,
and capability to produce more
than 1,000 eggs a day.
There were those who thought the worm’s
simplicity would render it useless in studies
of morphology and behavior.
But time and technology has turned C. elegans
into a molecular muse.
It has taught us about how life develops,
how human diseases progress, and how cells
die.
When Cobb wrote, “My experience in this
matter makes me very confident in saying that
professors of biology could do far worse than
to introduce into their courses a more careful
examination of these creatures,” he didn’t
know that one day, many of those professors
of biology wouldn’t just be introducing
nematodes into their courses.
They would be introducing them into their
labs.
When Cobb died in 1932, scientists didn’t
even know how genetic information was encoded
in DNA.
More than 50 years later, C. elegans became
the first multicellular organism
to have its genome sequenced.
And as it continues to teach us about our
world, NASA has even sent them to space
so we can learn about how life ages outside
of this planet.
So maybe the nematode is not the muse we expected.
But over the past century, they’ve become
one nonetheless.
And perhaps that is the most fitting testament
to what a muse often actually is, a surprising
source of inspiration that seems to come from
nowhere, and then permeates until you see
it everywhere.
We’ve been on a journey in this compilation
through knowledge and a growing appreciation
for worms.
And it brings us to our last video, where
we went from not just being resigned to the
presence of worms, but actively seeking one
out and dealing with all the surprising challenges
along the way.
We have spent most of our journey through
the microcosmos seeking out the organisms
that are too small to see with the human eye.
The bacteria, the ciliates, the tardigrades.
And Part of what makes them so exciting to
find is that they are so tiny. Every moment
we spend with one of these organisms is a
peek into something exceptional in our experience
of the world, and it’s the result of how
much work James, our master of microscopes,
has to put into hunting down as many microbes
as he can.
And sometimes, that effort requires a lot
of persistence.
Take the creature we’re going to focus on
today: the bristle worm. This has been one
of the white whales for our channel for some
time. And as you watch it, you can perhaps
understand why we have been searching so hard
for it. It’s got the body of a pipe cleaner
with the head of a cartoon dragon.
And maybe you also understand that just because
we’ve been wanting to find one of these
worms, that doesn’t mean we are guaranteed
anything. After all, one of the things you
have to accept about the microcosmos, and
microbe hunting,
is that it is a big world full of tiny creatures,
and it can take a while to find some of them.
The fact that we are showing you one of those
bristle worms right now spoils the twist we
would usually build into, but, surprise, we
found a bristle worm!
The real twist is that this was not the first
bristleworm we found.
This was the first bristle worm we found.
Twenty centimeters of segments and bristles
climbing up the side of a tank before burrowing
back beneath the sand.
Unfortunately, that’s just about all the
video we got of that bristle worm.
James spent so much time trying to find this
bristle worm again that he
started to feel a connection to it. So he
decided to give it a name: Gunther.
James spent hours trying to catch it without
hurting the worm. But Gunther has hundreds
of appendages that can grab onto sand, and
James didn’t want to accidentally snap the
worm in half with his tweezers. So instead
of showing all the features of Gunther that
we wanted to show, we’re going to show clips
of this bristle worm instead because it kind
of resembles Gunther, except a lot tinier.
Gunther is hopefully still somewhere in that
tank, living a nice life in the burrow it
dug for itself. But it’s hard to know exactly
where in the tank Gunther made its home because
it would only show activity in the dark. The
moment James tried to turn the lights on and
watch the worm in motion, it would vanish
again under the sand. And as it became harder
and harder to find, James kept hoping that
one day, something would bring another bristle
worm to him.
And then, one day, James received a package
from a coral farm containing sediments and
other things that might contain some interesting
organisms. We talked about some of those organisms
that James found in our last episode.
But in addition to all of those organisms,
James found several species of his long sought
after bristle worm.
Bristle worms are also known as polychaetes,
and they’re part of the segmented worm phylum
known as Annelids.
The name “polychaete” translates in Greek
to “many hairs.” Those stiff hairs are
called setae, and for most polychaetes, they’re
attached to paddle-like appendages called
the parapodia that branch off each segment
of the worm.
Our giant friend Gunther most likely belongs
to the order Eunicida, but its microscopic
look-alike is more unknown to us. But we can
imagine that it spends its life crawling around
the sand and feeding on algae, or whatever
else it can take a bite out of.
You can see this one moving its mouth in slow
motion, like a weird pair of pincers inside
clamping down on something, and the movement
is even more dramatic in full speed.
This probably looks like a bunch of tiny individual
orange worms tangled together. But it is,
in fact, a worm belonging to the genus Cirratulus
that can get to around 12 centimeters in length.
And along with its distinctive color, the
worm is easy to spot in wet sandy mud because
of those threads you see waving across your
screen. Some of these threads are tentacles,
but others are actually gills.
And in the water, those threads seem to float
serenely. But this effect is lost on land.
In a paper from the beginning of the 20th
century titled “Notes on the Ecology of
Cirratulus tentaculatus,” the author wrote,
“When withdrawn from the mud Cirratulus
presents an exceeding limp and bedraggled
appearance.”
This worm has a more imposing appearance but
also a funnier name. It belongs to the terebellid
order, but it’s known as a spaghetti worm.
These tropical worms live in sand, building
tubes out of gravel and limestone to live
in. Their tentacles spill out from the tube,
sometimes extending as far as a meter to gather
building materials and food for the worm.
To reproduce, spaghetti worms will release
their eggs and sperm into the water, but only
at night and sometimes even without other
males or females around. They seem to do this
on a lunar cycle, with a limited two week
window for these gametes to release and find
each other. That seems like an extraordinarily
chance-y way to reproduce, but it seems to
work for this worm.
These are the bristle worms we were able to
find from our coral farm samples. And so it
seems like our hunt for this white whale might
be over.
Except, the more we’ve been reading about
bristle worms, the more we wish we could find
even more. Because these are an animal whose
existence seems designed to inspire lists
of fun facts and bizarre trivia. There are
thousands of species of polychaetes, and they
all seem to have something remarkable or weird
about them.
Some spend their lives in tubes that stick
up from the sand, using their parapodia to
paddle water through the burrow. Others have
managed to carve out lives near hydrothermal
vents. Some sound like they’re straight
out of a horror novel, growing up to ten feet
long or dining on the bones of decomposing
animals. And some even have eyes on both ends
of their bodies.
So knowing that all of these different species
are out there, how could we ever end our quest
for the bristle worm?
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people whose names are on your screen
right now, they are our Patreon patrons.
Thank you so much to all of them,
and if you want to become a patron
you can go to Patreon.com/JounreytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, and why wouldn’t
you, check out Jam & Germs on Instagram, and
if you want to see more from us, there is
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.